is fall guys the next big thing ladies
and gentlemen
that's the question we'll be answering
in today's video and there's no time to
waste so let's
dive right in
people of the internet's retroreckons
who are here and welcome back to our
family friendly gaming channel
make no mistake about it fall guys has
taken the gaming world by storm
this is you one-on-one tim timmy
nice and easy let's go
you said it gonna be done there's the
king
put my crown on but is it poised for
long-term success
to start it really depends on how you
define the next big thing
by almost any definition fall guys is
absolutely huge at the moment
within 24 hours of release the game
already had more than 1.5 million
players
at the time of this recording fall guys
is still the top seller on steam
it's also free on playstation plus which
has nearly 40 million subscribers
don't forget a massive success on twitch
which according to twitch tracker by the
way the game has had an average
viewership of 174
000 over the past week so clearly
the game is huge but is it here to stay
can mediatonic sustain their early
success
i'm gonna give you five reasons i think
they can as well as one reason we should
all be concerned
and if this is your first time here we
post two gaming videos every week here
on youtube so consider subscribing to
the channel if you'd like to see more
fall guys content
let's get started with five reasons i
think fall guys is here to stay
number one it's unique arguably the
biggest thing fall guys has going for it
is that it's unique
there's really nothing else like it on
the market i mean where else can you see
60 jelly beans dressed as hot dogs and
pineapples racing each other through
american ninja warrior style
obstacle courses it's a completely
different take on the incredibly popular
battle royale genre
it's also one of those games that's easy
enough for anyone to play but difficult
to master
seasoned gamers who want to look for the
best possible strategies can do so
and it'll certainly give them the upper
hand but because of the game's random
nature even inexperienced players have a
shot at winning
in that regard it's a little bit like
mario kart but without the annoying
rubber banding mechanics that have
frustrated mario kart players for
decades now
number two it's marketable this one is
absolutely huge fall guys will be so
easy to market even outside of video
games imagine a fall guys
tv show i mean kids toys lunch boxes you
name it
the game's art style is bright and fun
it's family friendly and the jelly bean
characters are
instantly recognizable the game also has
non-invasive cosmetic only micro
transactions
and more importantly the cosmetics are
actually good like
really good companies want ip that's
gonna stick around though so fall guys
will have to continue proving themselves
over the coming months if you'd love to
see fall guys tv shows and toys go ahead
and give a thumbs up
on this video number three they have a
strong
social media presence mediatonic
owes their social media folks a raise
because they're doing
a phenomenal job they recently hit 1
million followers on twitter and if you
follow them you already know what makes
them so engaging
the account is witty and self-aware you
can tell it's someone having fun with
their job and not just tweeting
corporate bullet points they interact
frequently with the top streamers of the
game and are already running what is a
massively successful charity campaign
some of the biggest internet
personalities have been bidding huge
numbers on a charity auction in which
the winner
will get their costume added to fall
guys
mediatonic also did a great job
pre-launch when they emailed out
thousands of beta codes to streamers and
content creators both big and small
now if you're not too familiar with
mediatonic you're not alone
they're an independent developer but
they're one of the largest indie devs in
the uk
spanning across multiple locations
worldwide they were founded in 2005
and focused on flash games until
breaking into the console space in 2010
with who's that flying
monsters probably stole my princess and
one thousand tiny claws
they started working with devolver
digital in 2013 with a game called foul
play
which devolver published for both steam
and xbox live arcade
mediatonic partnered up with devolver
once again in 2014 for the release of
hadafall boyfriend which came out on
windows
mac linux ps4 and the ps vita
long left the vita but never in all
their years have they had such an early
smashing success like they've seen with
fall guys
number four it's perfect for updates
because of the fact that fall guys is a
battle royale comprised of a series of
mini games
the game is tailor-made to be updated
and perfect for the seasonal model
that's proven to be so successful with
other games in the space
mediatonic has already added one new
minigame and are sure to have countless
others in the works behind the scenes
in my opinion this one will ultimately
be what determines their long-term
success
how long can they keep the top streamers
interested in playing the only way to do
that is by keeping the game fresh with
smart updates that are spaced out
just the right amount there's a very
careful line here between
updating too much and not updating
enough mediatonic will certainly have to
prove they can find that line if they
want to maintain
their success before we get into the one
reason for concern let's go ahead and
talk about the fifth reason that i
believe fall guys is poised for
long-term success
and that is more platforms no not more
hexagon platforms
more video game platforms fall guys has
taken the world by storm despite the
fact it isn't even available on xbox
switch ios or android
the devs have already made it known
they're focused on steam and ps4
for now but they also stated they'd love
to see fall guys on all platforms
eventually
they've also said that it's their desire
for the game to be cross
platform ultimately getting
cross-platform working and releasing on
other platforms like switch and ios
would open up the game to
massive audiences on nintendo and apple
i see this game being
a huge success on the nintendo switch
i've already been hearing from switch
only owners who are just
itching for the game to release on
nintendo's massively popular console
so obviously fall guys has a lot going
for it at the moment the streaming
community is behind it the game is
selling like crazy there's a huge social
media presence
but as we all know success can be very
fleeting in the gaming industry
new games will come out vying for the
time of both streamers and everyday
gamers
but fall guys success will almost
certainly lead to copycats and
competitors
keeping that streaming community
interested and engaged will be key to
sustaining its success
which leads me to one of my main
concerns
and that is no esports presence
now let me be clear here fall guys
should not
have an esports presence in fact trying
to make the game more competitive would
damage its long-term prospects for sure
my main point here is that most games
that see that sustained
long-term success are games that have
some type of esports
presence think counter-strike league of
legends overwatch
sure there are plenty of games that
succeed on twitch without an esports
component but it sure does help games
stick around for years to come when they
do have that strong competitive esports
presence all that being said fall guys
is competitive just
a different kind of competitive if the
devs were able to keep the game fresh i
could almost see fall guys turning into
that game that
friends and streamers just play as
they're just for fun or secondary games
take someone like nick merks for example
one of the biggest streamers on twitch
clearly nick isn't leaving competitive
shooters like call of duty anytime soon
but fall guys could absolutely be a game
he plays when he's just looking to have
fun with friends or when he needs a
pallet cleanser from competitive
shooters
now i want to hear from you guys it's
incredibly early in the game's life
cycle but to me
fall guys has all the ingredients to
stick around for a long
long time it's just up to mediatonic to
capitalize
let me know in the comments if you see
fall guys sticking around or quickly
fading
let's go dude let's go
back until back
they were all standing around waiting
they're waiting for the crown to come to
them
no no no no no that's not how it works
ladies and gentlemen